Hãy bỏa tổng thịt mệnh lệnh của đồng chi cục chừng của cạnh sất xe ao thông về tăng cường
Kim chá, Kim sốt, xe liy vi phạm chất từ an toàn xe ao thông và hợp và tải hành khách,
lời Kim sất xe ao thông đường bộ có thúc xe sau, lựa sau, phòng sau,
cục cạnh sất xe ao thông đã khi đồng tối đàn được lượng, phương tịt, Kim sốt chặt chẽ và xe liy nghiêm các hình vì vi phạm.
Tương bí bộ giờ đến 1 xe ao dường ngày 20, 30 năm 2020, lựa sau đã tính hình Kim sốt 20 năm
tối đàn xe ao thông, khó đỏ lập bi bản vi phạm hình chính đối đối đối đối tình vi phạm.
Cú thị, lập bi bản đối đối đàn xe về hình vi, chừng người trên xe ao thông thông thách xe đại an toàn
tại các vị trí có trong vị trí đại an toàn xe, mức phạt tự tám trong nghìn đến 1 xe lông.
Lập bi bản đối đối đối đàn xe khách về hình vi khó thách xe đại an toàn,
tại các vị trí có trong vị trí đại an toàn xe, xe đại an toàn xe, mức phạt tự bà chân 5 nghìn đến 1 xe lông.
Tự tái cho thấy, nếu hình khách đều cho thành nghiêm việc thách xe an toàn,
thì trong khẩu ý phụ tên an toàn xo thông nghiên trọng vừa qua,
số người bị thương vong có thể đã giám đi rất nhiều,
hạn trên những mức mắt đầu lòng về tính mạng vào hộ quả năng này cho ra điểm và xã hội.
Vì sự an toàn của chính mình và cộng đồng,
hãy thách xe an toàn mối khi lên xe, dù ngồi vế hành nằm dù.